78 year old Sonia fajita opens the gate
to her family home or what is left of it
the six-bedroom house built by her
father in the 70s has been reduced to
Rubble
this was my room I would sleep at night
listening to the waves breaking on the
sand until I could no longer sleep a
couple of years ago I decided to move
out I knew the waves would soon topple
the house and that I would drown with it
she's not the only one in atafuna to
have lost all small fishing Town 300
kilometers from Rio de Janeiro used to
welcome droves of tourists every summer
until the sea swallowed up 14 blocks and
500 houses
geographer eduardois says the erosion
was caused by man and climate change has
made it worse atafona was built at the
mouth of the paraibodus river which
provided a natural barrier against the
sea
erosion began 50 years ago after
two-thirds of the river's Waters were
diverted to Rio De Janeiro affecting
about 7 000 farms and 600 factories the
river lost its Force to bring sand to
the beach and push back the sea the
waves have grown higher as climate
change raises ocean levels it's hard to
believe but I'm walking on what used to
be a paved Avenue the rubble behind me
used to belong to a hotel it used to be
the only four-story building in all of a
tafona and down there there were three
blocks of houses they have all been
swallowed by the sea
the coastline is receding an average of
six meters per year 50 families were
forced out of their homes
very few want to leave the city
sold his fishing boat to buy several
houses hoping to live off rent all
except two are under the Atlantic Ocean
I am not moving I want to live in the
house I built with my savings it's all I
have my life's work
Sonia is now living in a much smaller
house just behind the ruins of the old
one
it's very painful to watch your friends
and neighbors lose their homes their
mementos their livelihood but here we
all help each other and want to stay
close together in our beloved City
she says their shared memories of what
once used to be a lively Beach Resort
are what keeps this ghost town still
alive
Brazil